mesdames et messieurs bonsoir des
obsèques de monsieur robert boulin
disparu dans les circonstances tragiques
que vous avez ont eu lieu ce matin à
ville au grand petite localité située au
milieu des pins des landes et où le
ministre du travail était né il ya 59
ans au cours de l'homélie de
l'archevêque de bordeaux monseigneur
mazier qui célébrait la messe a évoqué
entre autres je cite la souffrance d'une
société profondément ébranlé inquiète de
son avenir est celle d'une nation
atteinte à travers l'un de ses meilleurs
séries telles un comme un père veut la
cérémonie par daniel gros comme un
soleil d'automne lumineux éclairait
villandraut un bourg de 850 habitants au
coeur des landes sénat que robert boulin
était né c'est là qu'ils désiraient être
enterré les haut parleurs retransmettait
le fils dans tout le centre du village
l'église étant trop petite pour
accueillir la foule devant le cercueil
un coussin sur lesquels deux croix
étaient agrafées la croix de guerre
la médaille de la résistance à côté du
cercueil la famille du ministre
sa femme colette son fils sa fille et
son gendre monseigneur mazières
archevêque de bordeaux célébrer l'office
il n'y eut point de mélie selon les
voeux du défunt élus pourtant des
paroles d'accueil
frère en vous accueillant dans cette
église
ce sont des hommes et des femmes dans le
coeur et être un parent la souffrance
que j'accueille ne souffrent d'une
famille dont j'ai partagé ici même un
événement joyeux et dont je partage
aujourd'hui avec une profonde émotion
un événement très douloureux souffrance
d'hommes et de femmes atteints dans leur
amitié leur attachement aux souffrances
de la ville de libourne rim et de son
maire souffrance d'une société
profondément ébranlé inquiète de son
avenir souffrance d'une nation atteinte
à travers l'un de ses serviteurs dans ce
monde d'agression ou l'homme et du
rebord l'homme qui d'entre nous en ce
moment
n'éprouve dans son coeur a besoin de
bienveillance de tendresse de pardon de
réconciliation
avec raymond barre est jacques val qui
représentait le président de la
république
17 ministres et secrétaires d'état
assistaient aux obsèques
marchant derrière le fourgon mortuaire
il précédait plusieurs milliers de
personnes
jusqu'au petit cimetière de villandraut
le matin même le clergé avait expliqué
que malgré les circonstances de la mort
les obsèques religieuses avait été
possible en raison du changement du rite
romain l'église s'en remet désormais
avec confiance au jugement
miséricordieux de dieu disait clergé
intercédant pour le défunt il fait
sienne la peine de son entourage
ltd ceux qui restent à partager son
expérience sur le caveau de la famille
ou là une simple gerbe celle de jacques
et micheline chaban delmas qui n'avaient
pu venir ce matin le moment peut-être le
plus émouvant lorsque la famille a reçu
les condoléances
salon barrillon bourges et surtout
michel debré
pendant plusieurs heures la foule a
continué à défiler devant le cagou
habits landreau robert boulin et ce soir
encore dans toutes les mémoires
daniel grandclément a indiqué à
l'instant comme le champion des masses
n'était pas là en fait le président
d'assemblée nationale qui est un ami de
fort longue date de monsieur moulin et
qui devait arriver par hélicoptère a été
très retardée parce que l'appareil n'a
pas pu décoller mais monsieur chaban
delmas est arrivé tout de même à temps
pour se recueillir sur la tombe de ce
monsieur bhl ou baromètre mensuel du
figaro magazine
monsieur giscard d'estaing monsieur bars
enregistrent une légère hausse 52% des
français font confiance au président
contre 51 le mois dernier 35 % font
confiance à monsieur bat contre 33% en
octobre parmi les autres popularité la
hausse de popularité la plus
spectaculaire est celle de monsieur
rocard qui gagne 4 points 47% des
personnes interrogées souhaitent du war
joue un rôle important il se retrouve au
premier rang à égalité avec adam
cimenterie monsieur chaban-delmas cannes
3 points messieurs mitterrand et
marchait en perd deux et ce sondage a
été réalisé par la sofres
entre le 18 et le 24 octobre les députés
du parti radical italien ont manifesté
cet après midi devant la prison de
fresnes à paris où est incarcéré pour
insoumission lorsqu'à terre général
monsieur fabre qui est de nationalité
française ils veulent ainsi protester
contre l'impossibilité de le rencontrer
hier après midi une délégation de leur
parti avaient été expulsés de l'hôtel
matignon
après avoir été d'abord reçu par un
collaborateur du premier ministre et
marco pannella leur leader leader de ce
parti radical italien est membre du
parlement européen dénonce ce soir je
cite le manque élémentaires de
courtoisie des autorités françaises ce
après midi la mère de jacques mesrine a
été autorisé à se rendre à l'institut
médico légal pour y reconnaître le corps
de son fils pendant ce temps les
policiers évacuent le véritable arsenal
qui se trouvait dans la dernière cache
de jacques mesrine rue belliard l'anb
xviiie arrondissement de paris porte de
clignancourt la circulation du marché
aux puces a remplacé la foule houleux
d'hier après midi quand le guet-apens
policier s'est joué en une poignée de
secondes à quelques dizaines de mètres
de là 37 rue belliard un attroupement
devant un immeuble discret là depuis
quelques mois jacques mesrine se cachait
sous le nom de paul tools journaliste
qui aurait pu se douter un instant qu'il
s'agissait de l'ennemi public numéro un
le grand comme disait ses acolytes à
commencer par charlie bauer qui l'a
trahie sans le savoir écouter d'ailleurs
un voisin son vis-à-vis du troisième
étage
mais ce qu il vous faisait la lure
d'impression d'un journaliste maintenant
son travail normalement
mcginn a trop on voyait c'était le matin
le soir de tous les saints du web on
voyait bien que ces commissions quant au
général n'ait pas eu à vous plaindre de
votre voisin l ai jamais été réellement
parfois il est très bien le mans vous
voiler une fée l'apport le charme et
montbérault ils sont des femmes nous
verrons venir s en soit aucun problème
dans la cour du 36 quai des orfèvres les
experts en balistique analyse les
trajectoires et les impacts de
projectiles
mesrine pour une fois ne portait pas son
fameux gilets pare balles et il semble
que les balle l'ayant atteint
provenaient les nouvelle carabine de la
police des calibres cinq 5 ans gi joe
qui pour la circonstance était confiée à
quatre membres de la brigade antigang
royal ayant participé à la grande traque
du gibier et à l'hallali d'hier après
midi
c'est pareil bon fourneaux de
baguenauder a encore une autre mais on
peut pas sérier les trucs et puis face
et les ensembles folkloriques et du caïd
et de sa dernière fiancée les policiers
ont découvert un véritable arsenal fusil
explosif grenade pistolet mais aussi les
lingots d'or et 250 mille francs en
billets qui proviendraient de la rançon
le lièvre est dérisoire une corde qui
pendait encore à la fenêtre de derrière
pour une évasion de plus ou moins cela
on l'avait sondé rancune à une clé de
bras
alors paul lefèvre la sla la ferme et
screen se poursuit
la mort du gangster est à l'action de la
justice comme l'envi personnellement ce
qu'il conserve mais elle n'a pas
interrompu bien au contraire vers
cherche d'abord la police d'ottawa clair
dans la longue cavale de jacques mesrine
pour l'instant les policiers dont au
moins deux personnes à interroger la
dernière maîtresse en date du gang stèle
celle qu'on appelle on appelait la belle
italienne et qui reste d'ailleurs le
symbole de cette sorte de fascination
que mesrine exercées sur ses proches les
femmes en particulier
sylvie jeanjacquot dont les médecins
disent ce soir qui est maintenant hors
de danger
et puis il ya aussi charlie bauer le
truand qui a été arrêté rue saint lazare
à peu près le moment où mesrine était
interceptée
charlie bauer semble avoir remplacé
pierre besse aux côtés de jacques
mesrine élèves une dépêche l'instant
vient de nous faire savoir que je
charlie bauer vient d'avouer d'avoir
participé à l'agression contre le
journaliste jacques tille
malgré cela il n'est pas sûr que ces
deux personnes se montrent très bavard
en revanche je pense que les policiers
dans les jours qui viennent vont arrêter
discrètement un certain nombre de
contacts que mesrine a eu pendant toute
la période où il était sous surveillance
en quelque sorte de la police en tout
cas la présence de charlie bauer prouve
que mesrine n'avait jamais rompu ses
liens avec ce qu'on appelle communément
le milieu il reste aux policiers donc à
tenter d'identifier d'autres complices
et et maurice bouvier le directeur
central de la police judiciaire a
clairement fait comprendre hier qu'il
s'apprêtait à révéler dans les jours qui
viennent une série de hold up et deux
attaques à mains armées auxquelles
mesrine se serait livré ces dernières
semaines en parallèle je pense que les
responsables de la police on va faire le
bilan de cette chasse aux gangsters et
doivent en tirer des enseignements
ma vie mais c'est la question que j'ai
posée aujourd'hui même ce matin à
maurice bouvier les structures normal de
recherche et d'enquêté at il répondu
sont parfaitement suffisante pour le
quotidien ce qui sous-entend l'une
évidemment que jacques mesrine sortait
de l'ordinaire méticuleux
dans ses déplacements habile dans le
choix de ses objectifs jacques mesrine
je ne pense pas trahir la pensée du
directeur central de la pj 10 hier
renforcer finalement le sentiment
d'insécurité des français et c'est
surtout en cela qu'il était l'ennemi
public numéro un le m10 conséquent ce
temps si je puis dire l'émulation dix
ans peut-être la rivalité entre divers
services de près cette concurrence cette
rivalité était néfaste elle s'ajouter au
danger que représentaient les réactions
de mesrine pour la foule qui l'entouré à
chaque fois c'est ce qui explique que
quatre fois les policiers qui avaient
localisé mesrine ont renoncé à
l'intercepter
on n'empêche que la ferme et free n'aura
pour conséquence de fait d'abord de
faire redescendre au contact du
quotidien l'un des plus hauts
fonctionnaires de police en france donc
de lui faire toucher du doigt
concrètement un certain nombre de
problèmes de coordination et de
fonctionnement
ensuite de vérifier l'efficacité de ce
plan de mobilisation générale tout
police et gendarmerie confondues qui est
employé seulement dans les grandes
occasions
la petite histoire retiendra peut-être
léon que la dernière fois que ce plan de
mobilisation générale a été employée
date du 22 août 62 au soir de l'attentât
du petit-clamart contre le général de
gaulle nous passons aux affaires
internationales ou québec publication
d'un livre blanc ou le premier ministre
de la grande promesse que la 2e rené
lévesque préconise une sorte de moyen
terme une troisième voie dirais-je entre
l'indépendance de sa province est la
situation actuelle c'est à dire le
fédéralisme il s'agirait une sorte de
souveraineté association le québec
recevoir la compétence exclusive sur son
territoire dans les domaines de la
justice des impôts directs des
transports et des richesses naturelles
avec edwards lors voyons les choses de
plus près mais ce n'est que dans sept ou
huit mois au printemps 80 que les
québécois auront à se prononcer par
référendum sur une question que l'on ne
connaîtra en fait que dans deux mois
pourtant à travers le livre blanc que
vient de présenter rené lévesque
on comprend déjà mieux ce que seront les
rapports dans les prochaines années
entre les habitants de cette province du
québec et les autorités fédérales du
canada c'est à dire le gouvernement
d'ottawa déjà par le titre du document
la nouvelle entente québec canada
une proposition formulée par rené
lévesque et les responsables du parti
québécois
proposition rejetée daisy hier par le
premier ministre fédéral joe clark qui y
voient une atteinte
aux aspects positifs du fédéralisme
canadien
pourtant dans ce livre blanc jamais une
seule fois le mot indépendance ne sera
employé
il s'agit en fait pour les québécois de
renégocier tous les contrats qui les
unissent aux autres états de la
fédération canadienne
en un mot d'acquérir une certaine
autonomie qui permettrait à la province
du québec d'être traité par la capitale
ottawa comme un partenaire d'égal à égal
et si les négociations pour une nouvelle
entente québec canada doivent durer au
minimum deux ans c'est ce que prévoit le
livre blanc le premier chapitre qui sera
abordé sera bien entendu celui de
l'autonomie économique on comprend mieux
cet objectif prioritaire des québécois
lorsque l'on sait que la province du
québec détient à elle seule la majeure
partie des ressources naturelles du
canada de believe in our souvent les
premières images du tout récent coup
d'état un putsch militaire du colonel
bush contre le président élu 3
auparavant
valter guevara ces images les voici dans
une seconde à la base l'intermède civile
n'a pas duré trois mois renversée jeudi
le président guevara n'était qu un
président de compromis les élections
présidentielles de juillet dernier
n'avaient pas permis de dégager une
majorité entre les deux principaux
candidats et le sénat chargé de les
départager avait désigné son propre
président
wahlberg eva pour occuper des postes
pour l'accent 89e fois depuis son
indépendance la bolivie assiste donc à
un coup d'état
le scénario est immuable on ne voit pas
ce qui pourrait venir gripper la
mécanique bien rodée en bolivie des
soulèvement militaire pourtant tous les
partis politiques sans exception
condamné le coup d'état
le président déchu a formé un
gouvernement clandestin les syndicats
faisant fi de l'état de siège proclamés
depuis jeudi paralyse le pays par une
grève générale la réprobation
internationale s'étend aux états unis
qui viennent de couper les vivres à la
bolivie enfin des militaires de haut
rang favorable au processus démocratique
aurait refusé de se ranger derrière la
nouvelle équipe au pouvoir en république
centrafricaine monsieur ange patassé
principal opposant au président bako a
été arrêté cet après midi à 40 km de la
capitale banques mais j'ai eu que feng
le numéro un chinois a accusé la
grande-bretagne pour l'italie dernière
étape de son voyage en europe qu'il
avait commencé vous en souvenez par la
france en reste avec une nouvelle
arrestation et il s'agit de signataires
de la fameuse charte 77 soupçonnait dit
la police de terrain en corée du sud
funérailles nationales pour le président
park son gré et un hommage vibrant à
celui qu'on appelle architectes du
miracle économique
mais ils sont aujourd'hui que son
gouvernement d'homme à poigne et
d'indisposer une bonne partie de
l'opinion et que son assassinat il ya
une dizaine de jours avait été précédée
par une réunion de généraux opposé à sa
politique jugée trop du message de
monsieur brejnev à la conférence de
lisbonne serait palestine la peine peut
être restaurée que par un règlement
global avec la participation de toutes
les parties intéressées notamment l'ol
paie unique représentant légitime dit le
président soviétique du peuple arabes de
la palestine à lisbonne même où nous
vous avons montré dès hier soir
l'arrivée de monsieur arafat et sa
réception par les grands leaders
politiques monsieur yasser abd rabo
porte parole de l'ump a déclaré cet
après midi à l'est
la fp qu'il fallait forcer des états
unis à reconnaître les droits du peuple
palestinien y compris par des pressions
financières et pétrolières si cela était
nécessaire
nous avons avec nous l'ambassadeur
d'israël monsieur mais rosen qui a été
l'un des principaux négociateurs du
traité de paix israélo-égyptien vous
même et votre gouvernement avait
toujours condamné le lpfc mauvaises
odeurs comment reçoit temps en israël ce
que j'appellerais sa percée diplomatique
et surtout ses premiers résultats
concrets et bien comme vous le savez les
négociations sur l'autonomie se déroule
très bien et dernièrement à londres la
semaine dernière on a fait des progrès
assez sensible or l'ol paie ne veut pas
que la population de la cisjordanie
participent à ces négociations
c'est pourquoi il veut obtenir la
reconnaissance par des capitales
européennes afin de dire à ces
palestiniens qui veulent s'asseoir à la
table de négociation et négocier avec
nous ce n'est pas la peine d'y aller on
va forcer israël à accepter
l'ol paie c'est ça le but de cette
activité diplomatique que nous voyons
les seuls ces dernières semaines
il ne paraît pas constate monsieur
l'ambassadeur en tout cas qu'il y a
aujourd'hui dans l'attitude de la lp une
sorte de revirement et qu'elle semble
passer du terrorisme avait diplomatie
mais pas du tout monsieur ya exactement
12 heures que l'ol paie amis des bombes
sur la ligne de chemin de fer entre tel
aviv et haïfa
il ya exactement 24 heures qu'ils ont
mis des bombes dans les marchés à
jérusalem malheureusement et je suis
désolé de voir que la presse française
n'en fait pas état de ces attaques
terroristes contre nous s'ils n'y a
qu'un mort de mort ce n'est pas assez
important pour le publier mais quant à
nous il s'agit de la vie d'un homme
d'une femme ou d'un enfant puisque les
méthodes utilisées elles ne sont pas les
méthodes utilisées par ce qu'on appelle
les mouvements de libération nationale
ce sont des actes de terrorisme
pour essayer d'imposer à israël sa
disparition parce que ce qui compte
monsieur si tron c'est ce qui est écrit
dans la charte palestinienne et dans la
cette charte palestinienne qui a été
d'ailleurs rédigé en 1964 c'est à dire
avant l'occupation des territoires par
israël
il est déjà dit et je cite l'article 19
au passage le partage de la palestine de
1947 et la création d'israël
sont nulles et non avenues c'est le
mannequin de l'ol paie c'est à dire 10
elle doit disparaître
d'ailleurs monsieur cadeaux mis lui même
a déclaré encore trois jours et vous
l'avez dans une dépêche de l afp
il a déclaré à correct même s'il ya un
état palestinien
le lp ne reconnaîtra jamais y serait
donc il ne s'agit pas ici d'une activité
diplomatique
il s'agit ici de la mise en exécution
d'un plan de liquidation de l'état
d'israël
il agit non imaginons sur baladeur que
monsieur arafat soit reçue
officiellement un jour en france comme
il est aujourd'hui au portugal
est ce que votre attitude va changer
tout d'abord je me refuse à croire que
le pays des droits de l'homme que la
france qui a donné au monde les
principes de la liberté de l'égalité de
la fraternité acquerrait un monsieur qui
dit tout haut et est clairement qu'il
veut liquider un état qui a des
relations diplomatiques avec la france
bien mais la question se pose pas mais
imaginons qu'elle se pose une question
votre attitude vis-à-vis de la france
par exemple va changer écoutez monsieur
je répète ce que j'ai dit je le refuse à
croire qu'une telle chose soit possible
pour nous c'était comme si on
accueillait en france hitler au jeudi
mais à l'endroit à la question vous
apparaissez depuis quelques temps comme
très intransigeant est ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'il faudra un jour ouvrir
des négociations non pas avec des
terroristes palestiniens mais avec entre
guillemets des diplomates palestiniens
mais chez tout d'abord je veux clarifier
une chose il ne s'agit pas d'un transige
ans israël a prouvé au cours de ces
dernières années qu'elle est capable de
faire des concessions extrêmement
importante autant renoncer à notre père
au pétrole du sinaï on a renoncé aux
bases aériennes du sinaï
on a renoncé à sharm el cheikh on a
renoncé aux implantations du sinaï et
c'est le prix que nous avons payé pour
la paix donc il ne s'agit pas ici d'être
intransigeant israël a offert de
négocier avec les palestiniens ce plan
de l'autonomie qui a été signé au cames
des vides
ces négociations évolué d'une manière
extrêmement bonnes et il ya toutes les
chances que les palestiniens bien se
joindre à nous à la négociation
ce qu'il s'agit ici c'est une une
tentative de nous imposer les
négociateurs et on nous dit après tout
la france a bien négocié avec les
hellènes
la différence monsieur est très simple
les fln n'a jamais dit que la france
n'avait pas le droit d'exister lfl n a
jamais dit que sa capitale est et paris
c'est ça la différence entre le fln et
l'ol peut s'en vouloir m'immiscer dans
les affaires intérieures de l'état
d'israël je pourrais rappelle son
ambassadeur que nul n'ignore qu'il ya de
graves dissensions dans le sein du
gouvernement béguines alors ce que l'on
ne pourrait pas penser par exemple c'est
une des hypothèses possibles que
monsieur begin ayant beaucoup travaillé
et ma foi ayant obtenu beaucoup de
succès un autre gouvernement qui le
remplacerait pourrait aller plus loin et
je cite ronde vous savez qui c'est le
seul pays au moyen orient où il ya un
régime démocratique ou en dépit d'un
état de guerre qui se posait depuis 31
ans
on n'a jamais regardé une élection et
c'est le peuple et israéliens qui
choisit son gouvernement en ce qui
concerne la non négociations avec l'ol
paie le peuple d'israël et unis 115
membres sur 120 membres de notre
parlement refuse à négocier avec ceux
qui disent que nous devons disparaître
et 115 membres sur sans vraiment de
l'assemblée refuse la création d'un état
palestinien qui deviendra une base d'
attaque soviétique contre tout le
moyen-orient et qui mettra en danger non
seulement la l'existence d'israël mais
la paix du monde
merci beaucoup de tous ces
renseignements ces ambassadeurs est ce
que vous avez dit complète les
informations que l'on peut donner
d'entendre qu'on dispose mais si nous en
venons à un problème purement française
je puis dire les petits bals du samedi
soir mettent souvent en évidence l'un
des fléaux de la jeunesse l'alcoolisme
la france est hélas le premier
consommateur au monde d'alcool avec
l'équivalent de près de 24 litres
d'alcool pur consommés par an et par
adulte de plus de 20 ans bien que tout
le monde connaisse des risques graves de
localisme et ses effets sur la santé
on note malheureusement la recrudescence
du fléau chez les jeunes de moins de 20
ans une enquête de pierre fouque
après guerre la consommation d'alcool
par la jeunesse était en régression
jusqu'en 1970 environ depuis
l'on observe une très sensible
augmentation de la consommation d'alcool
chez les moins de 20 ans les raisons de
cette recrudescence
elles sont multiples pressions d'action
publicitaire notion de fête en france
liés à la consommation d'alcool
initiation familiale à la consommation
besoin d'affirmation d'émancipation
pause sociale et économique
enfin et surtout l'ennui due à des
structures d'existence inadapté à la
jeunesse les univers de banlieue par
exemple où il n'ya souvent rien à faire
à grand chose enfin mr dans l'ain du
tout
vraiment on s'assied on a peu de travail
conjoint du tout au plus il fait beau
c'est sûr on va ce sera les gens sont
point d'accord c'est parfait genre ivey
aux bleuets le seul truc qu'on ait à
faire ce même pas de se brouiller
semaine passée à ses devoirs ou d'après
les moyens
un hiver à s'approprier quelque chose
qu'on fait moins d'heures pour que ce
soir là on a eu quand même quelque chose
en crépon à noisy à gauche on a vécu
avec moi qui tiens au nom
j'avais moi je réfléchis un petit peu
moins quand tu te poses la question
parfois pourquoi tu bois c'est pour
éviter ce même pas l'ennui c'est de ces
même pas passer le temps entre ses
vis-à-vis de mes copains pouvoir je sais
pas c'est une compression entre nous
tous on se comprend mieux comme ça j'ai
même pas encore ça c'est que lui à un
affaire il se trouve avec moi et moi
envers lui je me sens bien dans ces
états que lui envers moi c'est complet
on se raconte par les mieux entre vous
quand vous avez vu même pas si même pas
en ayant bu ça c'est qu'on se retrouve
exactement des combines s'ouvrait ce g7
ou g8 doit prendre si l'on peut faire
avec ça c'est d'après toi alcoolisme du
samedi soir
alcoolisme chronique
alcoolisme rural l'alcoolisme mondain
alcoolisme au lycée alcoolisme de
l'ennui ou des déceptions
autant de clichés mais aussi de vérité
qui se cache derrière ces mots clés
autant de facteurs de violence
d'accident ou de maladie chronique qui
tue chaque année quelques milliers de
français des causes multiples à ce mal
qui ronge et détruit et qui touche
d'abord un individu avec une vérité qui
est au fond de lui-même une fuite devant
le réel et la recherche une autre
personnalité
concernant l'alcoolisme chez les jeunes
le mot d'un éducateur illustre bien ce
phénomène il ne trouve pas dans la vie
quotidienne les raisons d'espérer
la véritable question savoir ce qu'ils
veulent faire de leur vie on va
travailler envers mes parents et pouvoir
sans ma vie moi même j'ai vachement
d'ici sais pas si tu vas bosser pour tes
parents et bah c'est pour toi en même
temps vachement bon
lorsque je peux faire moi même si je
trouve du travail serait première chose
la première raison je suis très déçu
deuxièmement j'ai moi-même pour résister
je crois que cet excès en france
l'alcoolisme tue 40 à 60 mille personnes
par an beaucoup d'entre elles ont
commencé à boire étant jeune simple
consolation s'il en était besoin la
recrudescence de l'alcool chez les
jeunes est un phénomène propre à tous
les pays développés à l'est comme à
l'ouest
alstom atlantique des négociations
directes entre l'intersyndicale et la
direction ont repris avec force et se
sont poursuivis toute la journée
je vous rappelle que l' usine de 7400
salariés et d'occuper depuis plus d'un
mois en cas de constat d'échec par la
commission de conciliation qui est
chargé de rapprocher les points de vue
l'application de l'arrêt de la cour
d'appel de besançon pourrait mener à
faire évacuer l'usiné par la fox sports
jean-pierre france de football sochaux
continue d'étonner tous les observateurs
cet après midi des sochaliens
facile vainqueur de metz 4e but à zéro
ont démontré un direct devant les
caméras d'antenne 2 qu'il fermait bien
l'équipe la plus surprenante de ce
championnat de france 79 400 grandes
vedettes mais un heureux mélange de
joueurs expérimentés et de jeunes
espoirs remarquablement dirigée par
patrick revelli face à m cet après-midi
ce show a séduit et justifier sa
quatrième place au classement général
premier but à l'issue de ce corner eaves
hip hop à tripoli
à tout seigneur tout honneur
un but hautement voit très rarement une
talonnade du pied gauche c'est un très
beau geste technique regarder
coup franc tiré par ea bozic du khalife
pour parizon 2-0 professeur à nouveau
parizon qui va inscrire un très beau but
une deux avec genghini demi coût 3 0
pour sow
c'était un tir instantané après une
rotation du corps regardez le travail de
parisot stopyra rentrer en fin de
rencontre déborde et centre
ivezic à la réception score final 4-0
pour ce show devant m non décidément
sochaux n'a pas fini d'étonner course
demain c'est le premier dimanche de la
saison de paix est d'emblée n'est pas
majeur le grand prix d'automne un
handicap sur les longues distances 4100
mètres 19 partants il n'y aura pas de
show favoris et la presse hippique
hésite elle partage ses pronostics entre
le 8 et chic y est un ancien très bon
choix qui vient de faire une bonne
rentrée le 7 pavon real qui est très en
progrès de 2 maroué récemment battu par
ces deux là mais dont on attend des
progrès le 9 pas vino un jeune de quatre
ans qui se lancent à la pac de chevaux
plus âgés le ciss faire comme
l'imprévisible et le 12 paires déchaumé
courageuses qui sont les deux doyens de
la compétition avec leurs neuf printemps
leurs neuf automne la course en tout cas
devrait être exceptionnellement
spectaculaire automobile comptant pour
le championnat du monde des rallyes le
tour de corse dont le départ a été donné
hier à ajaccio et pour la première fois
partagé en deux étapes ce matin après
une nuit faut le dire éprouvante et
concurrents sont arrivés à bastia où ils
sont répartis pour ajaccio il y a deux
heures alors que d'equipe darniche mais
est largement en tête
7h30 ce matin quelques kilomètres de
bastia fin de la première étape d'un
tour de corse nouvelles manières la
stratos bernard darniche et anahi
rejoint son assistance après un sprint
de 900 kilomètres qui la situe loin
devant ses adversaires
on pourrait d'ailleurs dire les rescapés
puisque les notaires descons durand
dû abandonner au cours de cette première
étape andruet béguin lemera serpaggi ne
sont plus là ils ont abandonné une
première lui difficile trop sans doute
s'est passée sans trop de difficultés on
n'a pas eu de problème mécaniques des
particuliers enfin des mines des
bricoles pour être en santé
les joueurs qui ne sont pas primordiales
heureusement la voiture est bien prévu
et toutes ces petites choses sont sont
pratiquement double donc on n'a pas eu
de problème particulier de ce côté là
mais la nuit a été quand même très
difficile parce qu'il ya eu la pluie
était très glissant et un peu de
brouillard
c'est quand même était pénible
nous quand on est devant comme ça quand
on est numéro un on sait pas du tout ce
qui se passe derrière
on ne voit jamais personne
eh bien apprenez de temps en temps par
les spectateurs sur intel avait
abandonné ou intel avait abandonné donc
en repartant ce soir dormi chez make
posséder plus de 13 minutes d'avancé sur
jean pierre nicolas et jean top 2e 3e
jean ragnotti et jean marc andrieu à 23
minutes et premier équipage féminin
michèle mouton françoise conconi 5e à
trente et une minutes que tels écarts
sont énormes et l'ambiance était plutôt
maussade ce matin à bastia
les organisateurs ont voulu rénover leur
épreuve en créant deux étapes mais du
même coup le tour de corse où dix huit
virages est devenu l'épreuve des trente
ou quarante mille virage deux étapes des
pilotes en général était favorable à
l'idée mais pas au point de leur entrée
un premier rallye puis un second en
l'espace de trente six heures et à
dernier rallye qui sera supérieure à
1000 km à sur le retour vers ajaccio
alors pour les retours du long week-end
de la toussaint la sécurité routière
prévoit plus d'un million
d'automobilistes sur les routes demain
dans la seule région parisienne entre 15
heures et minuit et en province
également les abords des grandes villes
seront très encombré et lundi il ne sera
pas facile non plus d'y échapper la
sécurité routière conseille donc aux
automobilistes ou bien de rentrer si
possible lundi 5 c'est à dire après
demain en milieu de journée
ou alors d'être de retour chez vous
demain dimanche à 20 15 heures le temps
qu'il fera le temps que vous
rencontrerez en roulant et miel sera
prêt nuageux sur la moitié nord de la
france que matin quelques pluies éparses
tomberont du morvan aux ardennes et aux
vosges ainsi que près des côtes
l'après-midi les pluies deviendront plus
marquée sur les régions voisines de la
manche sur la moitié sud du pays le
temps sera frais le matin avec des
brouillards parfois givrants et
localement de l'ale gelée blanche
surtout dans les langues le massif
central et les alpes et dans la journée
le temps deviendra généralement bien
ensoleillé et relativement doux pour la
saison ce n'est pas trop le journal le
dernier journal de ce soir samedi où
sera présenté vers 23h par pierre alain
et demain si telle est votre bon plaisir
nous avons deux rendez-vous à 12h45 et à
20 heures
bonsoir merci
à